around the world the race to develop a
vaccine against the new coronavirus
continues a pace the world health
organization is now tracking
more than 170 candidate vaccines
in the pre-clinical stage researchers
test if the vaccine triggers an immune
response in animals
in phase 1 testing the vaccine is given
to a small group of people
to see if it's safe phase 2 involves a
somewhat larger research group to test
dosages and in phase three the vaccine
is given to thousands of people
to make sure it's effective so far
there are no successful candidates
vaccines normally require years of
testing and time to build
up production volume the who has said it
doesn't expect widespread vaccinations
against coronavirus
until mid 2021 but even that
is optimistic
germany's top biotech companies and
clinics are rushing to come up with a
vaccine to defeat
the novel coronavirus some are already
carrying out human testing after the
lengthy approval process
was speeded up the stakes are that high
and so let's take a look at how the
trials work
a little pimp rick but it brings high
hopes with it
inside the syringe a vaccine from the
curvat company
it's designed to imitate the coronavirus
in the body to provoke an immune
response
about 200 people have volunteered to
take part in the trial
this way i can do my bit to help defeat
the virus
ten companies in germany are currently
working to defeat the virus
by developing vaccines
two are already testing their vaccines
on humans
in trials that generally consist of a
number of phases
after discovery in the lab there are
pre-clinical tests
then comes phase one which is mainly
focused on whether the human body can
tolerate the vaccine
and the reaction of the immune system
phase 2 looks at how high the dosage has
to be
and phase 3 tests effectiveness whether
the vaccine offers protection
in everyday life normally approval takes
about 8 to 10 years
but now the process is supposed to go
much faster
here at the university of tubingen
hospital scientists are working on phase
one
from the data so far we can see that the
vaccine is well tolerated and safe
and we also hope that the first signals
of the immune defense which are becoming
apparent
are also very positive
another company from germany is already
testing its vaccine on humans
biontech based in the german city of
mainz is partnering with the u.s
pharmaceutical company pfizer
they are already combining phases two
and three testing whether the vaccine
actually protects against coronaviruses
in everyday life
bion tech has around 30 000 volunteer
test subjects worldwide
it hopes to have an approved vaccine
before the end of the year
the head of germany's medical regulatory
body thinks germany is on the right
german track developers are well
advanced they're in a global premier
league
these are modern platform technologies
for vaccines
i expect that even two vaccines could
possibly come from germany
if there are more so much the better
a vaccine for everyone by early next
year
an ambitious goal that will require a
lot more pinpricks
well let's speak to professor ulrich di
nagal he's a neurologist
and founding director of the quest
center for transforming biomedical
research thanks for joining us
the search for a vaccine is all about
trading off speed and
safety how regulators managed to quicken
the approval process
without compromising on safety
i guess that's the 100 million dollar
question and it's so far unanswered
i think in principle speed and certainty
are at odds fundamentally
and so one has to make a trade-off here
this is about
risk benefit and i think
it's at the moment it's very much at the
discretion of those agencies whether
they are
accelerating whether they are fast track
approving
drugs in particular vaccines now or not
and a lot of this obviously is not
really transparent so we don't know much
about
those processes yeah i think what a lot
of people might be wondering is whether
or not
we can be certain that any vaccine that
does go through this streamlined
process is totally safe
uh certainly i mean there's nothing that
is totally
safe in particular not with vaccine or
drug development
and there are uh certain risks certainly
with
vaccines and they may even be late be
delayed those risks
um so that is obviously a very
um difficult decision
and at least i and i think i'm in the
community
with many others would argue that we
should not sacrifice
safety um for speed here because too
much is
at stake but in principle there there
although there are these rules uh and
you mentioned the phase one two
three and so forth um in the end it's at
the hands uh
and in the decision of the regulators uh
to fast-track and so
um we can only hope that there is good
evidence
um and that the evidence will be weighed
um
so far um it's hard to tell whether
we're on the right track we all know
that there have been drug trial that
there are trials that have been halted
one trial in particular
and there are concerns about the phase
one two trial from from russia
um so this just shows that this is very
sensitive and and
the public has to really follow this in
fact
right now over the weekend i think we
had the release of uh
trial protocols from the three major
drug companies that are running
those uh phase three trials which is
unheard of
and i think is a good development
because it allows
experts and also the public to
scrutinize uh what they are doing
yeah speaking of scrutiny we should talk
about russia which you did just
mentioned back in
early august they said that they'd
approved a working vaccine sputnik 5 as
they're calling it
but the international community the who
has basically rejected that but are we
any closer to knowing whether that is
an effective vaccine no not
at all i mean there was a publication in
the lancet only recently i think
less than two weeks ago um but uh
it it reports on a phase one slash two
trial that is open
and that actually has no true efficacy
endpoint it just looks at immune
responses it does not
look at whether it prevents actually
those infections
and it's a very small study and it has
raised concerns in fact there is an open
letter of concern
about the validity of the data and in
fact lancet has contacted the authors
uh to respond to it they have not
responded they have
said that they are going to respond but
they haven't done so yet so
we don't know it's very unlikely that in
such a short time period
any nation could uh determine safety and
efficacy
of such an approach now that continues
to be controversial that one
do you think what will come out of this
pandemic is
potentially a different model for
approving medication do you think we
will
have a swifter process going forward
well um we will see whether the bet
will materialize and whether these fast
developments actually pay off
that will certainly push it in this
direction but the the whole
issue of accelerated approval is
actually not a new development in fact
there have been discussions of this
topic uh for many years now especially
from
patient communities for example um
children parents of children with severe
diseases
who argue that they don't have the time
to wait for for large clinical trials
and that they want
almost experimental treatments right now
and we we should be aware of the fact
that
16 of the fda approvals right now
already are on an accelerated mode
so this is not a new development it's an
ongoing discussion
and many experts ethicists but also
biomedical researchers
are concerned about this because
we are lowering the bar and this certain
must
certainly increase uh the associated
risks
so at least thank you for bringing us up
today
i'm afraid we've run out of time we
could talk about this all day of course
professor oryx dear nagal thanks for
joining us
bye-bye thank you and now it's time for
your questions
to our science correspondent derek
williams
why has the covet 19 mortality rate
dropped so much i answered this a few
months ago but what was a fairly
tenuous trend back then has turned into
an
to an undeniable one today so i'm going
to answer it again
um first of all i need to emphasize that
that mortality
rate which is our best guess of the
percentage of people
who will on average die from the disease
if they contract it
that's only something we'll really be
able to calculate with any accuracy
after the pandemic is over what we can
look at now
during the pandemic is what's called the
case fatality rate which is
the proportion of people who have died
from
among the people who we know beyond
doubt have had it
the ones who have tested positive for
the disease and
as you rightly say that number has
fallen
pretty dramatically over the last few
months by around half
in some countries the experts say there
are
a couple of reasons why um first and
foremost
there's the experience factor the more
medical professionals all over the world
treat severely ill patients
the better they get at knowing how to
save them
then of course there's the fact that the
number of tests being carried out on a
daily basis is rising continuously which
means
we're catching a lot more positives than
earlier in the pandemic
when testing was was limited mostly to
to people who were
severely ill in hospital settings um now
we're also confirming a lot more cases
among those who have mild or or no
symptoms and that's related
to to the third factor the experts say
which is that the rise
in testing means that we're now also
detecting covet 19
much more frequently in young people and
as we all know by now they're much less
likely
to die from the disease than older
people are
finally some experts have expressed hope
that the case fatality rate is
maybe falling because maybe the virus is
now
mutating to be to be less virulent but
that's
still pretty highly speculative